Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je suis venu pour vous parler de quelque
chose qui vous concerne directement.
Cette chose qui vous concerne directement,
c'est votre pouvoir d'achat.
On est dans une phase où beaucoup de gens
vous en parlent, de votre pouvoir d’achat
pour vous annoncer d’ailleurs
qu’il va augmenter sans problème.
On est dans une phase -
Tony Blair disait que,
dans la vie d'un pays,
il y a les élections,
qui sont la phase poétique,
et ensuite, il y a la façon de gérer
le pays qui est la phase en prose.
Je vais abandonner la poésie
à la période que nous vivons
et je vais essayer
de faire un peu de prose.
La prose de l’économiste,
elle est aussi -
Si je le compare à l'homme politique,
reprenant une formule assez célèbre,
Jan Tinbergen qui était le premier prix
Nobel d’économie de l’histoire, disait :
« L'enjeu d'un homme politique,
c'est la prochaine élection ;
le devoir d'un économiste,
c'est la prochaine génération. »
Je vais essayer de vous parler,
pas forcément de la prochaine génération,
mais des quelques éléments
qui vont structurer notre vie future
à partir de ce qui vient de se passer,
concernant le pouvoir d’achat.
Pouvoir d’achat - comme toute notion
économique, il faut essayer de la définir.
C'est une notion que je ne définirais pas
de façon très précise -
vous n'êtes pas mes étudiants -
et vous savez tous ce que c'est.
Et pourtant, pouvoir d’achat,
ce n’est pas français.
Ça fait partie
de ces notions économiques
que nous ont imposées les Anglo-Saxons.
C'est le « purchasing power ».
En français, si vous prenez
un économiste du 19e siècle
ou du 20e siècle jusqu’à l’année 1950,
il parle de niveau de vie.
Je pense que le niveau de vie,
c’est quelque chose qui est plus complexe,
plus difficile à saisir,
et pourtant plus en conformité
avec la réalité de ce que nous vivons.
Le pouvoir d'achat, c'est quelque chose,
comme son nom l'indique,
qui consiste à associer
à une dépense un bien.
Le niveau de vie,
ce n’est pas uniquement la dépense.
C’est un cadre général
dans lequel se déroule la vie,
un cadre général
de richesse et de bien-être.
Je vais rester sur le pouvoir d’achat,
je reviendrai à la fin
sur le niveau de vie.
Alors le pouvoir d'achat,
il évolue comment ?
Il augmente régulièrement.
Sauf que la vitesse à laquelle
il augmente est en train de se tasser.
Grosso modo, entre 1960 et 1975,
il augmentait de 3,2% par an.
C'était les célèbres Trente Glorieuses
que tout le monde évoque
maintenant avec nostalgie.
1975, c'est la première récession.
C'est le premier ralentissement
significatif de l'économie
au niveau mondial - en tout cas, au
niveau des pays de l'Occident capitaliste.
Et cette cassure fait ralentir
le pouvoir d'achat.
Et là, on n'augmente plus
qu'au rythme de 1 % par an.
Jusqu’en 2001.
À partir de 2001, le pouvoir d’achat,
de nouveau, se met à reculer.
Il continue à augmenter,
mais le rythme, lui, recule,
la vitesse [diminue].
On est à 0,5% par an.
C'est le rythme actuel.
Alors pourquoi 2001 ?
Parce qu'en 2001, on décroche.
Nous décrochons parce que,
si nous nous comparons aux autres pays,
en 2001, on a un pouvoir d'achat
qui est à peu près proche
de celui de l'Allemagne de l'Ouest.
De l'Allemagne de l'Ouest
qui n'existe plus en tant que telle
mais qui a [encore] des statistiques.
Aujourd'hui, notre pouvoir d'achat
a pratiquement 20 % d'écart
avec le pouvoir d'achat des Allemands,
tout confondu.
Par rapport aux Américains,
nous avons 30% d'écart.
Et cet écart,
cette différence est apparue en 2001.
Pourquoi 2001 ?
Il y en a qui disent :
« Mais c’est l’euro. »
Sauf que les Allemands,
ils ont l'euro aussi.
La grande différence
entre les Allemands et nous,
c’est que, en 1997, Gerhard Schröder,
futur chancelier socialiste
social-démocrate,
rencontre ses camarades socialistes
dont le programme est le passage aux 35 h.
On lui demande :
« Comment vous envisagez
le passage aux 35 h ?
- C'est une très bonne nouvelle,
une excellente nouvelle
pour les salariés allemands
parce que ça va leur permettre
d'avoir davantage de pouvoir d'achat.
Effectivement.
Les salariés allemands travaillent plus,
et pour reprendre une formule là aussi
un peu dévergondée, un peu dévoyée,
un peu galvaudée par la politique,
travailler plus, ça permet de gagner plus.
Est-ce que l'économiste
pense la même chose ?
Eh bien, l’économiste pense aussi que
travailler plus, ça permet de gagner plus.
Les étudiants du monde entier
apprennent l'économie dans un livre,
un manuel qui a été écrit
par un économiste américain.
Forcément.
Cet économiste américain s’appelle
Nicholas Gregory Mankiw.
Avoir le Mankiw, c’est avoir le livre
de base de référence en économie.
Et Mankiw résume
ce que savent les économistes,
ce que peuvent mettre en avant les
économistes, au travers de dix principes.
Dans ces dix principes, le principe
numéro huit porte sur le pouvoir d’achat :
« Le pouvoir d’achat
d’un pays et d’une population
dépend de la production. »
Donc pour avoir du pouvoir d'achat,
il faut produire.
On produit comment ?
On produit en travaillant.
La production, elle augmente quand
l'efficacité du travail augmente -
ce qu'on appelle la productivité -
et quand la quantité de travail augmente.
Sur la productivité, où en sommes-nous ?
Eh bien, les nouvelles ne sont pas bonnes.
Nous avons un niveau d’évolution
de notre productivité
qui est revenu au niveau de 1820.
En 1820, les perspectives
étaient plutôt favorables.
On commençait la révolution industrielle.
Là maintenant,
la productivité stagne.
Elle augmente un peu,
mais elle a tendance à stagner.
D'ailleurs, nos dirigeants
s'en sont inquiétés.
Le gouvernement français
avait demandé à des experts
de se réunir et de définir les raisons
pour lesquelles la productivité stagne,
a tendance à ne plus augmenter
aussi vite que durant les années 60, 70.
Et tous ces experts sont arrivés
à une conclusion simple :
la raison pour laquelle la productivité
stagne est mystérieuse.
Ça ne va pas faire avancer nos affaires.
À partir du moment
où on ne sait pas pourquoi
cette productivité n’est pas
au rendez-vous,
c’est ce que les économistes
appellent le paradoxe de Solow.
Les ordinateurs,
les nouvelles technologies,
on les voit dans les bureaux,
il y en a partout.
Mais on les voit pas
dans les statistiques.
La productivité n’est pas au rendez-vous,
alors il reste le travail.
Évidemment, on peut essayer
pendant un certain temps d'y échapper.
L'État s'en mêle.
L'État peut permettre aux gens
d'échapper au travail.
On peut substituer pendant un
certain temps au travail de la dette.
C'est ce qu'on a fait en 2020.
En 2020, le pouvoir d'achat
n'a pas reculé.
La production a reculé de 8%.
Comment on a réussi cet exploit ?
Eh bien, 80% du pouvoir d’achat
qui a été maintenu,
80% de la différence entre l'évolution
de notre revenu, de notre pouvoir d'achat,
et l'évolution de ce qu'il aurait
dû être au travers de la production
a été absorbé par la dette publique.
Les 20% restants ont été absorbés
par les fonds propres des entreprises
qui ont quand même subi
des conséquences négatives
de l'interdiction qui leur avait été
faite pendant 55 jours de travailler.
Bon.
Est-ce grave ?
Pas vraiment.
C'est de l'argent magique, selon une
expression qui circule plus ou moins.
Sauf qu'il y a une conséquence indirecte
qu'on ne voit pas toujours,
c'est que lorsqu'on maintient
du pouvoir d'achat artificiellement,
lorsqu'il y a de la dette
et pas du travail,
ce pouvoir d'achat finalement achète.
Et s'il n'y a pas de production
à acheter, il achète quoi ?
Il va acheter la production des autres.
C'est le théorème de Schröder :
« C’est bon que vous fassiez les 35 h
travaillez moins en maintenant
votre pouvoir d’achat,
vous allez acheter du travail à côté.
Et le travail que vous avez à côté,
ce sera chez nous. »
Résultat, nous avons un déficit
extérieur considérable.
Résultat, tous les ans, la France
qui ne vend pas assez à l'étranger
est obligée de se vendre.
C'est-à-dire que nous vendons
notre patrimoine.
La Bourse de Paris est devenue
la propriété du fonds souverain norvégien,
du Qatar, de tout un tas de pays qui
dégagent des excédents extérieurs.
L'Avenue Montaigne est détenue à 80%
par des investisseurs étrangers.
L'Avenue Montaigne, le prestige,
la France,
Paris,
appartiennent à des étrangers.
Est-ce que c'est durable ?
La réponse est non.
La réponse, c'est lorsqu'on aura tout
vendu, on aura perdu notre souveraineté,
qui est un des mots-clés
du discours ambiant.
Et on aura perdu aussi notre capacité
à avoir de la richesse.
On travaillera pour les autres.
La génération qui vient,
tel que c’est parti,
on va lui demander de payer
les retraites de la génération
d'aujourd'hui,
et les retraites
des Norvégiens, des Qataris,
de tous les gens qui détiendront
le patrimoine français.
Donc il va falloir corriger tout ça.
Pour l'instant, il n'en est pas question.
La dernière fois que quelqu'un
s'est présenté devant des électeurs
en disant que la France
vivait au-dessus de ses moyens,
c'était Raymond Barre.
Le moins qu'on puisse dire, c'est
que le résultat était au rendez-vous.
Il n’en reste pas moins que
la France vit au-dessus de ses moyens.
Donc, si on veut équilibrer les choses,
on fait une politique d’austérité,
on abaisse notre pouvoir d’achat.
Finalement, ce que nous dit Paul Krugman,
prix Nobel qui a été abondamment
commenté dans la presse,
c'est que c'est ce que
veulent les Français.
Les Français sont pour les 35 h.
Les Français sont
pour la retraite à 62 ans
parce que les Français ont envie
d’avoir du temps libre pour se cultiver.
Vision positive de nous-mêmes.
Nous associons la sobriété à la culture.
Mais ce n'est pas forcément
la tonalité ambiante.
J'entends quand même des gens
qui réclament du pouvoir d'achat
et donc il faut augmenter la production.
Et pour augmenter la production,
notre travail [doit être] plus efficace,
mais la productivité se dérobe.
Alors il va falloir augmenter
la durée du temps de travail.
Évidemment à ce niveau de l'intervention,
ça fait que mon propos n'est pas
forcément parmi les plus populaires
des propos qui vont être
tenus cet après-midi.
Il faut travailler.
Bon.
Alors travailler comment ?
Quand on nous propose de reporter l'âge
de départ à la retraite de 62 à 65 ans,
c'est pour augmenter aussi
la quantité de travail.
Quand on veut réorganiser
tout ce qu’est le travail,
la façon dont nous travaillons,
réfléchir aux conséquences du télétravail,
développer et réfléchir
aux conséquences de l’ubérisation,
c'est avoir un nouveau rapport au travail
qui permet de faire
qu’on augmente la quantité de travail
sans en faire une véritable punition.
Alors, vous me direz :
« Est-ce que tout ça est possible ? »
J'avais insisté pour que
la présentation faite de ma personnalité
insiste sur le fait
que je suis né à Bordeaux.
Vous me direz :
« Quel est l'intérêt de savoir ça ? »
Eh bien, les Bordelais ont été d'abord
sous l'autorité d'un roi d'Angleterre
pendant très longtemps.
Il y en a un, Jean sans Terre,
qui est celui qui a été obligé
de concéder la démocratie
au travers de la Grande Charte,
la Magna Carta.
Dans la Magna Carta, il y a un article
que personne ne connaît
qui explique qu'on exonère d'impôts
les marchands et les producteurs
des deux grandes villes du royaume de
l'époque que sont Londres et Bordeaux.
Car « gens de commerce sont plus
utiles que gens de noblesse. »
Je crois que c'est assez vrai.
Ça a rebondi
avec un autre Bordelais, Legendre,
qui était le prévôt
des marchands sous Colbert.
Après une révolte fiscale,
les troupes françaises ont rasé Bordeaux.
Et Colbert, après avoir rasé la ville,
a demandé à M. Legendre au nom -
Colbert, c'était avant Bruno Le Maire,
le plus grand ministre de l’économie
et des finances qu’on ait eu.
Depuis, il n'y a eu que Bruno Le Maire.
Bruno Le Maire n'a pas rasé Bordeaux,
mais il reçoit aussi les patrons.
Donc on reçoit Legendre.
Colbert dit : « Qu'est-ce que
je peux faire pour vous ? »
Legendre répond : « Oubliez-moi.
La meilleure chose
que vous puissiez faire, vous État,
c'est de ne pas vous endetter,
de ne pas substituer
de la dette au travail
et de laisser les gens qui travaillent
profiter des bénéfices de leur travail. »
Je conclurai avec une seule formule :
« Qui non laborat, non manducet. »
Ce qui prouve que mon propos se met
sous la plus haute autorité intellectuelle
puisque c’est un extrait de la deuxième
épître aux Thessaloniciens de saint Paul.
Ça veut dire en français : « Celui
qui ne travaille pas ne mange pas. »
Si nous voulons du pouvoir d’achat,
du niveau de vie, du bien-être,
il va falloir travailler.
(Applaudissements)